sort of lost between the news of Rex
Tillerson firing and the firing of
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe was
the request and not really a request the
subpoena from special prosecutor Robert
Muller of the Trump Organization and of
course the Trump Organization is not the
Trump campaign the Trump Organization is
Trump's business entity and specifically
Robert Muller subpoenaed documents a
number of documents including some
related to Russia now this is relevant
for two different reasons before I get
to the one about the investigation let's
talk about the Moller part of this you
might remember that back in July of 2017
Donald Trump was asked by New York Times
reporters whether if Robert Muller
starts to look at his personal finances
his family's finances unrelated to
Russia whether that would signify sort
of the crossing of a red line and Trump
said that it would so let's review that
transcript from the New York Times where
Trump was asked last thing if Muller was
looking at your finances and your family
finances unrelated to Russia is that a
red line and Maggie Haberman added would
that be a breach of what his actual
charges and Trump said I would say yeah
I would say yes by the way I would say I
don't I don't I mean it's possible
there's a condo or something so you know
I sell a lot of condo units and somebody
from Russia buys a condo who knows and
then he goes on and on with his
unintelligible rents but the point here
is that Trump made very clear that if
Robert Muller went beyond whatever Trump
thought his scope should be at the time
into Trump's family finances which of
course mostly are tied up in the Trump
Organization that that would be a red
line Robert Moeller has now subpoenaed
documents from the Trump Organization
some of which are related to Russia
according to two people briefed about
this some of which presumably might be
related more generally to the business
and financial activities of trumps
business this is notable in part because
number one it's the first time that we
know of during the Russia investigation
where Muller is demanding Trump business
records and that gets us another half
step or full step closer to Donald Trump
personally which seems to be happening
every week
but the more notable part of it and I
haven't seen this discussed as much is
that there is a subpoena right all along
what Trump's lawyers have said is we
believe there's nothing here and we want
this to end
but we're cooperating with Moeller and
we are responding to all of the requests
that we get from robert muller
responding to requests doesn't
necessarily mean that they're giving
muller
the documents that he asks for and
that's what raises the question about
the need for a subpoena if you've given
a subpoena to the Trump lawyers for
these documents to me it means one of
two things one Moeller already asked for
the documents and didn't get them so now
he's subpoenaing the documents or he has
for some reason knowledge that
requesting the documents alone isn't
going to get them because the act of
sending a subpoena is newsworthy in and
of itself right so number one redline
possibly crossed
we've got McCabe fired Comey fired isn't
firing Muller the next step or at least
trying to that's number one and number
two why is it that a subpoena was even
necessary here and I was just thinking
how funny it was thinking back to that
July 2017 interview when Trump says it
would be a red line to look into my
personal finances isn't that basically
saying look at my personal find finances
it's like if someone says officer I
definitely don't know anything about
illegal drugs but if I did know
something about it I absolutely would
not have the legal drugs the illegal
drugs in my glove compartment so
definitely no need to look there at all
it's calling attention to where it is
that Robert Mulder should be focusing
his energy and if there is one good
piece of information related to the
possible firing of Muller it's that even
though we learned a few days ago that
this subpoena was submitted was served
to trump it actually is from weeks ago
so I'm sort of hoping that the fact that
the subpoena is actually several weeks
old means Donald Trump is not going to
fire Robert Muller since presumably he
would have already done that when he
learned of the subpoena again unless
Trump's lawyers are keeping news of the
Pina from Trump which I can't imagine
they are I don't want to dwell on this
aspect of the story too much because
there's just been so much Trump Russia
stuff in the last 72 hours but we're in
a situation where a subpoena of Trump
business documents is only ranking like
fourth or fifth in the major breaking
stories of the last 72 to 96 hours with
the the big picture is we are rapidly
heading towards a major confrontation on
this issue and quite frankly I
personally can't wait for that to happen
today's program is sponsored in part by
fruit or the tour is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board politics sports
so much more you wager on predictions
about real world events using food tours
in game fake currency and you earn more
of this currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on foot or you can find my account
by clicking the link in the description
if you're watching this on YouTube and
this week on future I posed the question
will robert molars Trump Russia
investigation end during this year
during 2018 what do you think place your
bets and you can sign up now at
futurecom and start making your
forecasts on political topics and so
many other topics it's free and it's
available on both Android and iOS as
well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm